for these people
jankowitz more like jenko halfwitz
i workshopped that for hours
it's tales of russian collusion from
biden's department of delusion and yet
more proof the head of biden's disinfo
board
is out of her freaking gourd
i speak of nina jankowicz aka crazy tick
tock show tunes lady aka head of
homeland security's newly created
disinformation board if her videos were
any nuttier she'd come out of an
elephant's ass
because they ate peanuts
the washington examiner uncovered more
of her old tweets and it turns out in
2016 she had no problem pushing this
since debunked claim
in that trump had ties to russia's alpha
bank she shared a tweet from hillary
clinton about the bogus claims a week
before the 2016 election that quote
tweet a pile of garbage from slate in
read in part it's time for trump to
answer serious questions about his ties
to russia trump has a secret server it
was set up to communicate privately with
a putin-tied russian bank called alpha
bank yeah the server was so secret
didn't exist
turns out jankowicz spreads false claims
the way brian stelter smears peanut
butter on his naked chest
with both hands and a big smile across
their face
i hope that's burned into your brain
in recent years her greatest hits
including debunked stuff and the
infamous steele dossier is dwell well as
doubting the hunter laptop story if this
was 20 years ago she'd have you
investing with bernie madoff
and the origins of those bs alpha bank
claims are now the focus of the trial of
michael sussman the clinton connected
lawyer charged with lying to the fbi
when he brought them a tip about a
possible trump russia link
hmm
clinton connected
our condolences for his upcoming suicide
i'm joking
for his sake i am
rob so uh even if even if this lady
the head of the ministry of truth is
incompetent what if she was confident
isn't it just a bad idea even if they're
good at it it shouldn't exist no it
shouldn't exist it's a terrible idea and
these people remember you know the book
1984 they made a movie out of it they're
trying to make the movie look like a
documentary right and you know what
these people are trying to do and she
said before they want to edit your
tweets so it's not that they want the
they want to control everything that's
going on it's not that they want the
truth out there they want their version
of the truth out there and these are the
same people that are telling you that
there are 100 different genders these
are the same people that are telling you
that men can get pregnant right and so
these are the people that want to be in
charge of the truth of this country it's
completely absurd no they are she her
idea of what a fact is is only has only
become relevant in like the last seven
or eight months she's just a walking
twitter trend cat i am worried about her
because we have not seen her
anywhere it's like she fell off the face
of the earth like mary poppins got stuck
in a tree
are you worried because she's someone
who clearly has an interest in musical
theater and those people don't go out no
the oh hey that's it
maybe that's it what is musical theater
exactly i don't know because i'm cool
you know what i have a feeling i've been
feeling that right now guy is burning up
no i am really i'm actually i am really
i'm just like i'm sorry musical theater
but look how cool i am i look so cool no
i do i look like your dad's
sassy cool paralegal slash your soon to
be new stepmom
hide your dad so i took dad
she just did violence to half of this
set
yeah that is a homophobic hate crime two
gay guys on set you're gonna come after
musical theater we see you cat
we see you
and i'm having a meeting with hr right
after this
you can go ahead and do that but
they'll be so intimidated by how cool i
am yes as is everybody like oh music
like that's the worst thing like do you
see she tweeted she was or she was
talking about how in twitter they want
she wants verified check mark people to
add context to tweets i don't want
anybody associated with the government
doing that and the the second person on
that list would be someone who likes
musical theater right
guess i think imagine i can't even think
of one uh musical tyrus that i actually
liked like i said i've sat through some
and and it's you know it's not pleasant
does that i guess that makes me
incredibly heterosexual
[Laughter]
[Applause]
huh
i love me some women
that was convincing yeah was that
convincing it was really convincing i
took tight i went to what's it called
exodus for six years i don't know what
it
is oh my god a conversion therapy joke i
reflect on the first that is sarah thank
you very much yes thank you very much
you didn't even know what i was talking
about so privileged to be on set for
that
tyrus so anyway what do you think where
is she what's going on
i feel like anything i say right now is
going to be held against me so
i like it
nina's watching yeah i know
you know
[Applause]
yeah i've seen that look before
at least on four different occasions
there is no one that can do this job no
exactly there's no one that can do this
job there's no one that's not going to
push their own biases and if it was a
republican board it would be the same
thing the only thing i would ask is that
they would pick somebody
not a walking
oxymoron for the whole idea i mean she
picked
everything
that was a lie and fought to make it a
truth i think you can be on the wrong
side of something right we've all been
there but you need to be able to
acknowledge that like yes i thought that
trump was connected to those two banks
and i was wrong
suddenly you have a little more
caveat like okay you know what there's a
reasonable person but that's not what
they do
they were just like it must have been a
different bank they just keep going yeah
yeah yeah yeah
we got the wrong bank going it's like
when you do go to a musical and they say
three acts when you get to the second
act you're like
tell me about that what else is there
left to sing about oh yeah yeah
you know
well first of all wait wait i gotta get
guy in here uh because god you know when
i'm at home watching nascar with my
babes
i'm wondering it's like
we just found out about this lady she
must be doing this information for years
before we found out that's exactly what
i said to my babes while watching nascar
oh yeah
yeah you know i have a i have my own keg
machine you should come by keg machine
yeah why don't you you should come by
after work it'll just be me and my babes
oh look the babes aren't here guy uh
what do we do
[Laughter]
like uh
guy will hope he handled those babes
[Laughter]
they had to get up early guys this is
just you and me in this
bottle of champagne in the hot tub oh
my maid's out we have no clothes
i should stop now
going
huh
know i'm i'm building an hr case right
now it's like keep going just keep going
okay hr understands that we're artists
just not musical theater artists so
i i want to agree with something that
tyra said i disagree with one thing he
said no one can do this job
and i agree with that the job should not
exist right it should not exist at all
i'm actually glad though that biden or
whoever it was picked her because she
she is so
self-discrediting she's this wild
crazy-eyed mary poppins cartoon
character who i think is preferable to
someone who might sort of seem more
serious and more even-handed she isn't
that
so obvious i think that actually does us
all a service that is true kind of like
if they if they actually had somebody
that could fit the bill
that
we wouldn't see how absurd the whole
idea is excellent point guy that's why
it's guy town
up next make up a phony crisis to label
parents as isis hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else